so wardrobe season has been in full
swing and we have seen some amazing
looks already makes us very excited but
we're going to see at the Oscars this
Sunday but let's take a look at our
favorites this season there's Aubry
Plaza at the SAG Awards can we talk
to you guys think of this look
I I I didn't like it at first and now
wait no no and now I like it well
actually I liked all these women showing
skin but again I was like I didn't like
it at first and now I love it it took me
I love it first I don't care what she
wears I think she's a genius amazing
unbelievable actress who has timing is
perfection like her dry sense of humor
is so genius and I'm just obsessed with
her so I don't care what she wears oh
what did you know I agree with Christian
absolutely yeah I I I love it all right
what about Jennifer Coolidge she's
having such a moment of course
funny
this is her at the Golden Globes what do
we think age appropriate best part of
her body showing yeah and I love that it
was sent along like yeah oh yeah because
she is not typically a Saint Laurent
girl but I thought that out she looks so
Chic and again age-appropriate and
everything
pushed in the right place it was
stunning I love her I love women too
that get better every single year yes
like we watch legally on in our house
all the time and that was 20 something
years ago and she looks better today
than I mean even more beautiful she got
to style her for Ariana Grande's um
thank you next video you did I did yeah
oh and that was a major career it was
the only major yeah Ari had to have her
you know sometimes you get around those
girls and they're everything that you
thought they would be and you just like
ah but yeah you should hear the voice
memory I'm such a fan at 2AM do you
really get your voice for years and let
me tell you the voice memos the book
sells itself yeah the audiobook that I
could just they mean nothing Christian
did you like it I loved it okay great
okay this look you did for Quinta
Brunson at the Golden Globes was one of
my favorites I've seen
[Applause]
did you because how tall is she she's
tiny right and Melissa we're both short
girls like how did you make her look so
tall yeah she's very wow very Tower over
her yeah and usually when you're short
you don't do a lot of fabrics and yeah I
think I think that's what she wanted she
kind of wanted a little bit of a
princess moment but also like we just
want to have fun with this I think she
just wanted it to be playful romantic
ethereal she was wearing a lot of
um quite sexy corseted saying so I think
this was a bit softer more romantic I
think her stylist um Brian Jabbar made
an excellent choice with this and I'm
sure she has on the tallest shoes
like this tall
[Applause]
props to you especially when you're that
little and you want that it all is and
you know this tailoring the tailoring
yeah
it was impeccable okay Zendaya at the
SAG Awards law again you hit it out of
the park oh my God I mean it's not a
single thing tell us the story of this
look together so P Apollo is actually
funny Pier Paolo agreed to make the
dress we had five days so he pulled his
entire Atelier in Rome it was 40 people
um
Valentino it was like a thousand roses
and
yeah he made it happen but this this is
what I meant by the new Hollywood glamor
yeah you know the young girls that have
a respect for the girls before but want
to do it their way
[Music]